so I saw across the spider-verse and
yeah I thought it was amazing or should
I say spectacular pun intended on both
accounts so let's get into it everyone
and their mother has talked about how
incredible the movie is how diverse and
engaging its art direction is just it
really fires on all cylinders but for me
one of the most impressive and brave
things about the movie is in the
structure itself any normal movie is
made up of three individual Acts one
pertaining to a certain part of the
story that's integral to a person's
enjoyment of it but this movie is
essentially when you break it down a
First Act and only part of a second act
and while that definitely has ruffled
some feathers not mine personally I
think it was done exceptionally well I
think it's also worth thinking about how
ballsy that decision was like your
studio puts out one of the most
critically acclaimed 3D animated movies
of all time the sheer creative courage
it takes to answer that call to action
by saying all right okay look this
sequel is going to be one half of a
story it's immense